hello citizens of the reject nation so
i was able to watch the new predator
movie pray pretty early now only social
media embargo has lifted so i really
cannot say much on this film so instead
what i want to do is show you guys
something but before i show you guys
this i should let me let me explain
they sent me a screener of the film
early because they wanted me to
interview the director and stars of the
film which i already did and honestly
it's some of my favorite interviews ever
i'm gonna be putting up on the channel
next week and also you know really quick
before those comments come in
and i'm not saying this to be cool or
anything like that if i don't like a
movie or something like that i'm going
to be honest i don't really care
to change my opinion just because i'm
interviewing someone involved with the
film i mean just watch our mortal kombat
reaction our hawkeye reactions our
eternal's reaction uh i was definitely
not shy of harsh criticism even though
we interviewed people involved with
those properties but what i want to show
you guys i actually of course shot a
reaction to this film can't even get
around to editing it until the movie
actually releases so in the meantime
what i wanted to show you guys is this
i'm gonna play for you exactly what i
said right when the credits started
rolling then we're gonna come back here
and i'm gonna elaborate a little bit
more
[ __ ] yeah we got a great ass predator
movie
not since the first one we finally got a
great predator movie
holy crap
that was great that was really great
holy god i just
this franchise been so up and down and
we finally got a great ass predator film
i was so happy with that man that was
amazing i loved the first predator movie
i have a nostalgic place in my heart for
the second one i liked predators uh
didn't really like the predator but this
one this one is easily the best one
since the original there's an argument
to be made that this could be the best
one i don't want to declare that until i
watch this at least like two more times
because that would be a pretty bold
statement the film's only 90 minutes
long but it's freaking solid like
everything name a category directing
cinematography mood tone atmosphere
pacing
action the violence the performances
i've never cared so much about a main
character in this franchise before until
this film watch it when it comes out
keep a lookout for my reaction keep a
lookout for those interviews i did too
please but yeah i'm like
i really want to get the word out on
this movie if you like the trailers
you're more than likely going to enjoy
this film everyone i talked to that has
also seen it really liked it a lot too
or loved it if you've fallen off of the
predator franchise give this one a shot
seriously
whoa
i [ __ ] love this movie
[Music]